good morning hank it's tuesday i still
have a mustache because of a project for
awesome promise and my voice is a little
bit horse sorry about that but greetings
from my basement where the confetti
is vast and the exhaustion is profound
you know what let's just go on a walk
as i'm filming this we've just ended the
live stream of the 2021 project for
awesome which has so far raised over two
million dollars for charity by almost
any metric this has been the most
successful p4a in the project's 15-year
history and i am
so so grateful to everyone who
participated
not just by donating but also by making
p4a videos and voting for charities and
the endless brilliant
jokes and memes shared in chat a huge
group of volunteers work on the p4a to
make
it run but we also count on the
volunteer efforts of everybody who's
watching whether it's reminding each
other to stay hydrated or developing
perk ideas related to hank's
bean furby which i guess is now known as
beanie sand firms i should add that when
this video is uploaded the p4a
fundraiser will still be live it goes on
until midnight
eastern time tuesday so if you want to
pick up any last second perks
now is the time the digital download
bundle available for a 60
donation is always the best deal of the
p4a as it comes with all kinds of
digital gifts that will arrive
throughout the year but
you can also get everything from the p4a
t-shirt to the commemorative coin with
which to celebrate these strange and
lovely 48 hours
hank crash course co-founder stan muller
has said to me that when you're living
in the middle of history
you never know exactly what it means and
living in this strange and extremely
difficult time
i don't know what it means i don't know
how we will look back
on this or for that matter when we will
look back on it
this is the first time in my life when
you can say it and have most everyone
know
exactly what you're referring to it
is hard it is a grind it
is isolating and exhausting it is also
of course temporary when i said recently
to my therapist that i felt like we were
never going to get out of this
she said well but remember that
everything else has ended
which is the kind of hope that i can go
in for the kind that isn't bs or
pollyanna-ish but is real
and verifiable everything else ends
so will this i say in an episode of the
anthropocene reviewed
that the light soaked days are coming
and i really believe that
it is february there's snow on the
ground the trees look dead
but they aren't dead e.e cummings wrote
that
spring comes carefully out of nowhere
and it always does how can something
that happens
every year be a surprise
but it is for me the great joy of the
project for awesome this weekend wasn't
that we blew past even
our most ambitious fundraising goals or
that hank's bean furby became a
celebrity
the great joy was being reminded that
even amid
it light-soaked days are possible
or even if not entire days then little
moments
little moments when we make it easier
for each other
or even wonder filled this weekend i
laughed and i cried and most of all i
felt
connected to people again i was reminded
that humans are
really good at being together and
working together
collaborating across time and space to
make and do things that none of us could
do alone
this weekend reminded me of that that we
are together
even when we can't be so thank you
thank you thank you hank
i'll see you on friday